[Music]
still Alice stars Julianne Moore and is
a story about a woman who discovers that
she has very early Alzheimer's and this
is a very smart woman she's a teacher
she feels a lot of pride about the
things she's able to accomplish in her
life and all of these things make it
very difficult for her when she starts
to realize that she's forgetting very
small things in her life her daughter is
played by Kristen Stewart who is also
having a very hard time adjusting to
this obviously this is a very
heartbreaking movie at times filled with
excellent performances all around I
really did like this movie despite the
fact that there are aspects of it that
do come off a little bit like Oscar mate
there are times where movies just come
out in like two theaters or maybe even
one theater at the end of December
simply to be Oscar qualified and then
finally like in the middle of January or
even in February people can suddenly see
this movie but I'm really pleased to say
that Julianne Moore's work in this movie
is very subdued it's not showy it's not
like hey look at me I'm an actress I'm
gonna cry and moan and bawl throughout
this entire movie she actually gives a
very nuanced performance that feels very
level-headed and what I mean by that is
nothing about her performance screams
look at me she's so famous at this point
that it's hard to not see Julianne Moore
but in this movie she sunk so deep into
this character and she gave such a
realistic portrayal of what it would be
like for a woman who is entirely about
her brain I mean this woman lives by the
fact that she is so smart that she's
able to teach students and that she is
just really good at everything she does
and the fact that her most precious
asset her brain is now failing her is
truly heart-wrenching and Julianne Moore
did a tremendous job portraying that
also I really do want to focus on Alec
Baldwin now I've liked this guy for
years as an actor he's hilarious he's
given good performances since like the
late 80s and early 90s but I was
concerned about his character in the way
that we're gonna take him once her
Alzheimer sets in or they're gonna do
all these cliches they tend to do with
the nasty husband I was so pleasantly
surprised to actually see a portrayal of
a good husband in a movie and that was
awesome because I'm so used to these
cliches where as soon as one character
is suddenly going through a hardship the
mate or the spouse has to
run out on them it was so nice to see a
well-rounded and realistic portrayal of
a husband dealing with something that's
now happening to his wife in a good way
in a positive way because there's tons
of real-life human beings out there who
deal with this on a daily basis and tons
of fathers and mothers and daughters and
sons who continuously support these
individuals but those are rarely ever
portrayed in movies because those types
of relationships are more boring there's
not as much drama there still Alice was
like who cares we're gonna show a family
that tries to support this woman without
a whole bunch of random shitty drama and
I love that about this movie now as her
flaws already mentioned there are some
moments where this movie feels a little
bit Oscar Beatty where they have these
really long drawn-out conversations
about not much really and there are some
times where the movie drags because it
feels like they're repeating certain
scenes over and over again and I'm not
just talking about the fact that she as
a character has to do the same thing
sometimes because she forgets what I'm
referring to is that sometimes the film
makes a point and you're like okay I get
it but then they keep kind of hitting
you over the head with it throughout the
movie you're like I get it I get the
theme you're going for let's move on to
a different thing now these are all
really minor complaints though because
the movie as a whole is just a great
character piece and it's a great
performance by Julianne Moore guys I'm
gonna give still Alice a B+ it does feel
a little Oscar Beatty at moments but
Julianne Moore's work in this movie is
so good that is definitely worth seeing
and I love the portrayal of realistic
characters in a family attempting to
deal with something this tragic and that
is definitely praiseworthy guys if you
did see still Alice I'd love to know
your thoughts on it and as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]